I did a search on Hammerball and variants and also Jack Hammer amplifier on item I saw
when looking over the true right website came up empty so two questions. One, I know
the Hammerball was intended as a sleeping partner that you get right next to which I do
nightly. At what distance is it so weak that it's of no real benefit? So if you're using
the bulb without the Jack Hammer amplifier it can be about three feet away from you and still have
some benefit. Of course the farther you move away from you the less benefit so that's why I
tell you to snuggle with the bulb. But if you have the habit of the thing falling on the floor
you're really restless at night or the thing ends up being four by six feet away from you everything
recording when you wake up then getting the Jack Hammer amplifier would be a wise thing to do
because that really pushes it out a number of other feet. So I've said multiple times the Jack Hammer
amplifier really is necessary for most our patients unless you're going to do it during the day
since I tell people to snuggle with the bulb but we have some patients that just can't snuggle with
the bulb and they get the amplifier so that they could put the bulb under their bed. Now we said
all our patients and are you know with the Jack Hammer amplifier comes with it but anybody that's
purchased it right from us or the plan from us you know prior to two weeks ago that you didn't get
it in the unit to purchase it separately from true right. So but I still I personally don't use it
because I have them all right next to me and I really doesn't go anywhere so it's still snuggling
it's right up next to my body when I wake up in the morning so but if you wake up in the morning
it's four feet away from you and it could have been like that all night and getting the Jack Hammer
may be the thing to do to get. So number two is the Jack Hammer something I should look into. Well
those circumstances prevail and yes doesn't extend the range yes it extends as the range does it
boost power well it just extends in the range so you you yes you have more amplification
um so but if the bulb is right next to you without the Jack Hammer it's still going to go through you
so you know if you if you have the habit of sleeping right next to it and you always use it with it
right next to it then you don't need the Jack Hammer but if you used your right but different times
where the bulb is two three four feet away from you then get the Jack Hammer. I'll make a video about
this and put it up on the side too.